me it's about  living within your own self  i think the biggest issue for so many  people especially as you told me about  your audience is they over worry about  validation from the outside whether it's  about their appearance whether it's  about how much money they make whether  it's to make their parents proud which  is a nice thing  the only way to actually get to that  place that you really want to get to  is putting your fingers in your ears and  living in your own world the cocoon you  create for yourself  is the place that you could be most  happy because when you actually need  outside validation you will always  always be vulnerable